you a recluse like him when you're on
the road uh yeah pretty much I kind of
just chill
I don't really do my show and then go
back to the hotel when Chris was single
I just tell him this one story no no no
no no way
no we can cut it out no stories no way
my parents are gonna hear this [ __ ] it's
not a sexual know already know oh my god
me more about coffee er better are you
backing me out for some why are you
backing up right now I lose this whole
[ __ ] interview you've been backing up
to the [ __ ] wall like exposure to
many people in this there's a lot of
yeah yeah you okay I'm good dude oh you
better [ __ ] believe it
[Laughter]
bro I don't say gross [ __ ] all right I
apologize because we're outside look I
remember when I first came over to this
apartment yeah I couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
I couldn't believe how your wallpaper is
I couldn't believe it that you live like
this
yeah and you do you know what it is what
when I was about a boy a little kid we
wanted to get like an Atari and my mom
goes no right you have to do homework
right and you know I didn't get certain
things right so when you make enough
money yeah wouldn't you want to buy the
things you want to buy right I
understand that
but you should want to buy different
things that was a space wallpaper did
you put that up or did you have someone
put it up I a guy that I worked with on
a show put it up Wow here's a set design
the guy she paid him to do it no but he
probably just didn't leave money like
you [ __ ]
fadna what up - I know dog the good life
huh I don't have network TV money Ivan
he shows on when that guy went
undateable got canceled it across you no
no no I was bittersweet man it was like
such an awesome show to be on but I did
it for three seasons and some do so it
was really good guest starring on it you
know yeah do the opportunity again to
act with your friends it's just really
man we didn't have that many guest stars
okay we had we had there were eight
eight leads yeah okay so thanks for that
we wouldn't have been on season four
yeah Whitney all those like the lines
you gave me for Whitney well that was
really old like I was in control of that
thanks man
that's real nice you know you could be
on my next one oh thank you
all right you know what you can't be the
audition which I read for you [ __ ] I
mean let me tell you something well this
story okay tell this story about how
they they came in and you went to test
for something on a Saturday and you and
you said and you walk in and you were
about to do your audition and you went
nobody told that story I hear on this
podcast yeah I don't know oh and I
watched all that you would tell every
store okay so then you're done making
the podcast no okay before the Connie
Chung story were you [ __ ] your pants
yeah yeah of course my favorite thank
you any other stories and an even worse
audition last year though really
they Amy Poehler one oh I'm sorry I
didn't mean a believer again you already
told it on the popcorn oh okay yeah we
did we talked about it I'm sorry you
don't have to relive it why are you
doing that I'm sorry but do it quick to
me Joe it just it was just you know I
didn't think she was gonna be in the
room right but I went in and she was in
the room and then she took to
introducing me to people and I'm like oh
I'm gonna bomb right and that completely
just flubbed it and then when I left the
[ __ ] audition I hit a bottle of water
and I hit my head over the head with it
like a thousand times
oh boy who was bleeding no yeah no yeah
i torture myself whoa like Silas doesn't
like the division yeah literally
you know what dude it's like I have such
PTSD when it comes to auditions that it
really started to me there really yeah I
bet you kill it though I can I have oh
yeah I have to but yeah every once
awhile but when it goes bad yeah like
what last week I did that read for that
one with Ike in it yeah it's called the
pact you read for though no and I know
the Eric Griffin about to be a lot of
read for it so I go you know you know
did I went in and I thought I had it
down yeah and then I just lost it yeah
and then I leave and I go oh I'm so much
better than that yeah that's what
happened it's weird too because like
guys like you I know what you can do so
it's weird that you're even auditioning
anyway kind of you know yeah but they
don't know right you know what they do
though they do though you think they do
yeah they do
yeah you're telling me somebody doesn't
know it but there's that whole there's
the process which sucks you have to go
and you have to [ __ ] audition and if
you don't I'm gonna make do it it okay
imagine like who name some people that
you think you're as famous as me yeah as
yes I feel like I'm as famous as
Sebastian I guess right but he does
stand up and not I'm saying an attitude
of acting I think I'm as funny famous as
Tyler Labine right well yeah
you might be maybe maybe maybe but you
know what he's gonna do
Yeah right yeah why do you have to
audition him he doesn't get auditions
what do you mean he gets offers well so
what I'm saying I saw him at an audition
once oh you did yeah Oh for me it's this
is is that I'm sure he gets offers to he
does but I know that he he gets a lot of
love yeah but with me is because I'm
number one I feel like because I'm my
reputation is that I'm I get naked a lot
and crazy you know I'm not being real
maybe people go because I'll do a job
like I'll get offered a job I'll be on
set they're like wow you're pretty
normal maybe what do you mean they go oh
we just thought that you would be like
tearing this [ __ ] place right you
know it's like I don't do that right
yeah you know you don't do that at all
yeah like I you give you do you I you
get me a job that music video right I
think
you self fulfill it though you know what
I mean like I feel like you exacerbate
that I feel like you think that about
yourself so people think that about
yourself
I always thought that about you hmm
that's a fair assessment yeah I'd have
to agree yeah it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy dude if somebody said to you
like okay so what you're saying is that
my dick is so big though it's so I was
joking it's not that so what you're
saying
it's pretty good though it's healthy but
yeah but but well I'm saying if somebody
came up to you yeah you're in a position
where if somebody came up to me and said
hey yeah I heard you're crazy and you
might tear up the set and you went like
this really you're [ __ ] crazy they
might feel stupid right but you don't
you don't give that impression you're
like oh you heard that about me all [ __ ]
and they're like yeah and dude this is
probably could I just say something
right now this is probably the most
realistic and here's what ever said to
me well yeah if you stayed and actually
hung out after at a diner maybe you'd
have more of these conversations that's
the truth dude instead of we're gonna
talk instead of bringing out Toki the
dumb dumb plants vs. zombies and then
jetan dude yeah yeah you pay for
everybody know what I usually put on the
table or everybody you want Toki down
down time I mean I kinda have 50/50 yeah
it is funny yeah great
okay you're right dude you know what
yeah you know what itself it's
self-image mmm and I should I should
really just kind of you know look at my
life and go you know what you've done a
lot and you're talented guy and how do
you deal with failure like when things
just if you go in it yeah like how do
you deal with it all
because he likes to hurt himself more
than the he likes to hurt himself ten
times over for about three weeks I just
it sucks you know like my like like look
my my most recent thing was that the mic
went out of the thing and I thought it
was in my head for the whole first
taping of the first special I did the
second one and I was like [ __ ] man I
feel like I [ __ ] failed that and the
truth is you know I probably did it
probably like if I cut the special out
of that even the first the first shot
people probably be like oh you know
funny like I but but I so I had to talk
myself into that and I was like I had to
shoot another show in [ __ ] 40 minutes
and I was like I could either dude you
could either let it bog you down or you
can [ __ ] use it and make it better
right like I mean that's what athletes
are supposed to do right like you fail
you have a bat you're bad you you
[ __ ] strike out you strike out you
strike out you strike out and then until
you're like enough Sanaa and then you
[ __ ] turn it around or you let it get
to you and you keep striking out right
right but can I ask you this have you
ever like wanted something and not
continent well yeah okay
I mean you know like all the time okay
especially in the business yeah yeah but
that's why I do stand-up cuz you can't
make me not have something I'll just go
up on stage and then I'll have that you
know what I mean yeah but like but like
acting work all the time dude yeah yeah
yeah it makes no say nothing makes any
sense anyway in that world to me so yeah
it doesn't make anything you know I mean
I walked in and I did a thing I thought
it was a funny thing I took a I had to
take on a character where I was like
this aggressive like jersey dude I'm
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that and they were
like I was really funny Thanks and I
left and then my agent was like hey they
thought you were too aggressive and I
was like why the [ __ ] didn't they just
tell me not to ask me not to like yeah
yeah yeah I've had that you know what I
mean that's that makes no that makes
zero sense yeah so why did you stand up
and I'm in control of that yeah we are
blessed to do it and that's why I kept
telling you yeah no you're not listening
right now yeah you were going yeah or
something
[Music]